je m'appelle Méline Lee je porte ce que
je veux je dise que je veux 24 heures
sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
me voilà j'assure mais j'ai pas le temps
de m'amuser
c'est pas facile tous les jours pas vrai
ça va être la meilleure année de toute
ma vie et rien ni personne ne m'arrêtera
le petit déjeuner est prêt
j'arrive
tout va bien chéri
je suis un gros monstre dégoûtant
regardez pas laissez-moi
qu'est-ce que tu as dit
nos ancêtres avaient un lien mystique
avec les pandas roux non mais c'est une
blague ou quoi c'est une petite
excentricité dans notre famille
[Musique]
chance on dirait une peluche c'est
horrible on t'adore mail sur
[Musique]
n'importe quelle émotion forte va
libérer le panda
[Musique]
tu réalises à quel point c'est dangereux
si tu t'énerves c'est le panda assuré
je le crois pas
toute ma vie j'étais la gentille petite
mémère je me sens plutôt bien panda
pauvre chérie
[Musique]